during my time with elvin ring i
couldn't help but reminisce about some
of the older games in the soulsborne
franchise but more specifically the one
that got me interested in the series in
the first place that being dark souls 3.
so with eldoning bringing in newer
players and dark souls 3 approaching 6
years old i thought it would take some
time today to talk about the game and
all its features as not only is this one
of the best in the whole series it's
perfect for newer players that just got
introduced to the soulsborne games with
elden ring as i believe it provides the
smoothest transition into these games
thanks to its similar mechanics with
that out of the way like the video if
you enjoy and let's get started
and so it is
that ash
seeketh embers
so dark souls 3 is the third in what we
assume to be the final part in the dark
souls series the fire that lights the
world is once again fading and it's our
job as the ashen one to rekindle the
flame just like with many of the
soulsborne games the plot is quite vague
and will continue to get more obscure as
we continue but don't worry about the
story so much now as we'll discuss that
a bit later as for its gameplay it has
mechanics taken from past games but it
also introduced unique mechanics that
were carried over into elven ring most
of the areas to an extent are quite
linear but do include many classic
design decisions included in previous
games like illusionary walls multi-level
floor plans and shortcuts these have
been a staple of the franchise since the
very beginning and it's no different in
dark souls 3. where the game does differ
though is in its moment-to-moment
gameplay as dark souls 3 introduced the
fp bar for magic weapon arts for all
weapons and the ability to heal while
moving among many other changes it's
clear from the footage that elven ring
and dark souls 3 are very similar to one
another especially when compared to the
previous games which is why i believe if
you're here strictly for the gameplay
alone then there's no perfect place to
start than with dark souls 3. now that
the basic synopsis is finished let's go
a bit more in depth on those previously
mentioned topics so before we even begin
we have to pick our class there are 10
starter classes all of which have
different stats to allow for different
ways of play as you approach the end
game in new game plus the starter class
matters less and less but it can make
the early game a bit easier by choosing
one that fits your preferred play style
one of the benefits of the dark souls
series is that many mechanics classes
and styles are the same so it makes you
feel comfortable in its gameplay without
even starting the game this is shown in
the starter classes as each of these
classes were not only in previous games
but also future titles so no matter what
game you plan to play there's always
going to be your go-to starter class
where this ideology falters of course is
in its stats as while most of these
stats are consistent across the series
there is the occasional one that does
get a change vigor attunement and
endurance level up the health fp and
stamina bars respectively vitality
increases equip load allowing you to
wear heavier armor without fat rolling
as well as slightly increased physical
and poison resistance strength dexterity
intelligence and faith are all combat
stats that can grant you the ability to
hold specific weapons and do more damage
with the help of scaling and the final
one is luck which increases item
discovery and curse resistance there are
some smaller additions to these stats
like dexterity decreasing how long it
takes for you to cast the spell but
that's the basic gist of each of them
each of these stats gives the player the
opportunity to really shape their build
to their liking but i'd be lying if i
said all of them were useful luck and
its many other iterations have always
been useless to me as items are still
quite plentiful without increasing their
drop rates and many of the items you do
use are considered static those are
items that have set spawn locations like
boss weapons rings and many consumables
obviously having a 99 in luck as opposed
to one is quite a drastic change but is
it really worth wasting a level on it
especially when in the early game when
you can level up quite fast by far my
least favorite stat in dark souls 3 is
vitality increasing physical and poison
resistance is nice but once again is it
really worth a level plus armor can
provide similar benefits for less work
this means that this stat is strictly
for increasing equip load which is an
atrocious decision the quip load
obviously has its benefits but wasting a
level on it to increase it by 1 is a
complete waste of time this also makes
it harder to partake in fashion souls as
many times an outfit will look nice but
will put you over the 70 equip load
causing you to fat roll this sounds like
a weird thing to complain about but i've
never cared about stats on outfits even
in souls games so while i don't mind
when the game takes away my defensive
capabilities once my fashion is ruined
is where i have to draw the line in all
seriousness though vitality isn't a
useless stat it's just more confusing
because dark souls 1 literally had a
much better way of handling it as it's
tied to your stamina stat this is the
same for elven ring so at least this was
changed in future titles the rest of the
character creation is the same as the
other games where you customize your
character's appearance as well as choose
a burial gift that you are given upon
starting the game speaking of which we
can now get into how the gameplay
actually functions once the game begins
if you've played any other dark souls
games regardless of whether it's older
or newer this layout should feel right
at home to you left and right for your
left and right hands down is for the
quick select inventory and up is for
spells the game also has classes of
weapons to further develop your
playstyles like small and fast weapons
which can be scaled with dexterity or
slow but hard-hitting weapons that can
scale better with strength magic is also
split into three schools which are
sorceries pyromancies and miracles
sorcery skill whether with intelligence
miracles are better with faith and
pyromancy is a mix of both when finding
either a weapon or spell a list of
numbers will be shown at the bottom
which are a minimum stat requirement for
them to be used a lack of intelligence
or faith and a spell will not even make
the spell appear and a lack of strength
or dexterity on a weapon will allow the
player to still wield the weapon but it
greatly reduced damage i've always been
a fan of melee build so majority of the
footage in this video will be me using
my old build that i started on my first
playthrough which was just a pure
strength build usually accompanying
strength is a set of large armor which
more often than not has a lot of poise
poise has always been a unique and
confusing mechanic to wrap your head
around as sometimes it seems like it
does nothing but something at the same
time at least for dark souls 3 poise
helps with hyper armor a mechanic that
allows you to power through an attack
and continue your swing poise can also
affect enemies as sometimes they can
power through your attacks this is
mostly seen in larger enemies but
depending on your poise and the weapon
you use to attack them you can still
stagger them should an enemy or boss be
staggered this will either lead to a
free hit or two or sometimes can lead to
a riposte which deals massive damage
repasting an enemy can be done after a
parry as well but that is a little
harder to land regardless poise is a
very weird mechanic and one i still
haven't been able to understand but i
don't really think too hard about this
stat is what really matters though is
the weapon you're using just like in any
souls game all weapons are viable but
it's clear that some weapons are just
better than others finding the weapon
that works for you is incredibly
important as at least in my opinion i
find more success sticking with a weapon
rather than upgrading a complete new one
just because it's better against a
specific boss such as in this fight
against gale here where i found that
because of the timing of my weapon and
how long iframes last on a dodge i can
dodge the first attack swing to get some
free damage then have enough time to
immediately roll out of the next attack
and perform another for free damage if i
would have used any other strength
weapon this attack string wouldn't be
possible most of your success in boss
fights does come down to memorizing the
boss's moveset but it's also just as
important to understand your own
limitations so you can prevent the fight
from lasting too long however there is
nothing wrong with switching weapons and
equipment if you desperately need to and
the game almost encourages this by
giving you tons of upgrade materials
titanite is the material used in all
upgrades many weapons will require
standard titanite whereas other weapons
like magical equipment and boss weapons
will require twinkling titanite or tight
knight scales the highest upgrade is
plus 10 for the larger batch of weapons
while the other weapons that use other
titanite upgrades will only go to plus
5. this is because more often than not
these weapons have unique abilities or
movesets that set them apart from
traditional weapons making them unique
items the easiest way to find titanite
is to hand in the appropriate ashes to
the handmaid at firelink shrines you can
purchase them but even if you can't find
these ashes the drop rate for these is
incredibly forgiving as in areas like
smoldering lake or lothric castle not
only were enemies dropping lots of
titanite but loot drops found on the
ground containing titanite were
everywhere the third additional method
to finding titanite is either from the
little lizards around the map or the big
ones that you can kill as for magic just
like in previous games while you can
upgrade the chimes and staff that use
the magic you can't actually upgrade the
magic itself this is of course done by
leveling up the respective stat that
being intelligence and faith spells can
be acquired just like weapons can which
are from merchants drops and bosses but
you can also find tomes that you can
bring to merchants allowing you to
purchase more spells from them but magic
also underwent the biggest change within
the series with the introduction of the
fp bar in past souls games magic was not
taken from the fp bar when it set a flat
number given to the spell itself so on
one hand we have a magic system that has
unlimited uses as long as you have fp
which can be refilled thanks to ash and
estus flasks and the other system that
gives the player limited uses but
removes the fp allowing you to mix and
match however you want without worrying
about the cost of course the question
then becomes which is better and
honestly it's a tough question to answer
not only do i rarely use magic in these
games but both do have their own
benefits in the case of dark souls 3 it
allows you to have a steady supply of
magic whenever you want but it also
comes at the cost of your estus and your
stats no matter the starting clash your
fp bar is going to be low so it's
important to level this up but now that
means you have fewer points going into
other stats on my current strength build
i prioritized health stamina and
strength which is only three skills when
using magic it's important to level up
both attunement and stamina so you can
cast more spells health for obvious
reasons and then intelligence or faith
depending on the magic bringing us to
four however if you wanted to dabble in
both miracles and sorcery or if you're
just trying to use pyromancy then you
need to level up the other stat bringing
our total to five that's a lot of stats
to keep track of meaning you're going to
be weaker for a larger part of the game
thanks to having average stats and 5
skills as opposed to above average stats
and 3. furthermore you need to allocate
the flasks you have so you can have a
good amount of healing and magical
flasks available too many on one side
either means you can cast more magic but
can't heal as often or heal more but at
the cost of less magic although to be
fair given the play style and health
that magic builds have if you're getting
hit you're most likely dead anyway this
also runs into the issue of leveling up
those said flasks because the item s
dishard will give you more flasks up to
a total of 15 you can mix and match but
at the beginning you don't start out
with that much and depending on how many
of them you find you may never even have
enough making the experience less than
enjoyable but magic builds are still
viable in dark souls 3 and they always
have been but it's clear that they'll
become more powerful much later than
their melee weapon counterparts however
if you're willing to play along with the
added challenge magic is a blast to use
and a really humbling experience if
you've only used melee weapons the final
category though we haven't discussed yet
in terms of weapons is ranged and to be
fair i don't really have a lot to say
about them i've always felt that ranged
weapons were really just gimmicks used
in challenge runs but if you do want to
use them the option is there dark souls
3 has standard crossbows and bows but
also heavier versions called grepos
which i'll admit are pretty fun to use
if you do plan to use only ranged
weapons for a build be prepared to use
the same weapon for a very long time as
not only is there not a large amount to
choose from that just being seven bows
seven crossbows and three great bows
many of them aren't found until the
latter half of the game all of these
spells weapons and armor though do allow
the player to mix and match not only
their build but their fashion giving
them the opportunity to really play how
they want but to even start this process
we have to go to firelink firelink
shrine is the game's base of operations
you can level up sell items upgrade
weapons and talk to npcs similar to
equip load dark souls 3 changed
mechanics that probably really didn't
need changing as to use all the
aforementioned mechanics you have to go
back to firelink which is done by
resting at a bonfire and teleporting to
it this in general is not a major
problem but it's definitely an
inconvenience when you have to go to a
bonfire to teleport to firelink do all
of your business then go back to the
bonfire just to teleport back to where
you left off after finding the right
weapon for you though the next step is
to infuse it collecting certain pieces
of coal and returning them to the
blacksmith can unlock new gems you can
infuse with standard gems like sharp and
heavy can increase the scaling on a
weapon while more unique gems like blood
and chaos can add ailments to the weapon
these not only have gameplay benefits
allowing you to really push the damage
on your weapons but also further your
preferred build such as a bleed-only
playstyle of course while this is great
we really do only care about the boss
weapons after defeating curse erotic
greatwood a very early boss in the game
you're given a transposing kiln that
will allow you to spend bottles in
return for getting their magic and
weapons each also has two items to buy
so that makes 46 weapons in total the
player can acquire the problem is that
you're only able to get one soul to
unlock all these items so if you want to
get everything you'll have to get the
first half on the first playthrough in
the second half in new game plus once
again elder ring would fix this issue by
giving you the chance to duplicate them
is this starting to get old i am sorry
but it's incredible how many quality of
life changes actually exist in that game
but i'll stop bringing it up once you
take all of this into account you can
really see how much your damage is
affected by this upgrades and infusions
are really where the majority of your
damage is going to lie as my exile
greatsword was a weapon with 148 damage
and a c in strength but now ends at 600
damage with an a in strength one thing i
really appreciate about this game is
that as long as you're willing to look
around the map you'll find all the items
you need this also leads into the next
section which is the level design dark
souls has some unique elements of its
level design that really set it apart
from other games the main feud just
being the secrets in form of illusionary
walls or hidden locations as well it's
unique addition to traps first location
you start in is the cemetery of ash and
while you might feel inclined to go
straight ahead if you take your time and
look around you'll find a large crystal
lizard that gives you some early
titanite while this isn't a huge secret
it may be something that the player may
never find as they're so focused on
going straight ahead in the next area
which is a smaller section of lothric
castle you can find numerous areas that
you may not have found if you didn't
look around enough but technically these
aren't hidden they exist in the game's
world and are right in front of the
player they just need to look around a
bit this is in stark contrast to some
areas that are completely hidden
smoldering lake is a completely optional
area that you may never find when
entering the catacombs of karthus you
need to cross a bridge that you can
fight a boss named wolmir who upon
defeat will break the spell sealing the
door to irithyll however if you went
back to that bridge you can break it
this is really effective for when those
skeletons start to chase you across the
bridge but if you wait long enough a
prompt will appear allowing you to climb
down that broken bridge into smoldering
lake most devs wouldn't even try to hide
content that probably took months to
complete but from software is so
confident and has no problem making an
entire location some players may never
even see but as cool as the level design
and combat are what's more exciting to
talk about is the bosses
dark souls 3 has 25 bosses throughout
its main game and dlc making it actually
the lowest of the trilogy with dark
souls 1 having 26 and dark souls 2
having 41. so you would think due to the
low number the team focused on quality
rather than quantity and barring a
couple of them you'd be correct dark
souls 3 has an exceptional lineup of
bosses and one part of these bosses that
need some praise is the gimmicks or
rather the additional elements added to
the boss fight to clarify a bit a good
example is the ancient wyvern which is a
giant dragon except this boss is located
just beneath a drop-off point allowing
you to one-shot them with a plunge
attack this addition to the fight is
much different compared to the standard
1v1 and a flat arena like vort who does
change up his moves a bit when entering
the second phase but the fight is still
the same out of the 19 bosses in the
base game four of these bosses have an
addition to their boss fight in the form
of a weakness we've already talked about
the ancient wyvern in his weakness but
the other three are great wood wolmir
and yorm greatwood is a rotting tree and
his weak spot is the white pus that
grows on his body you'll more than
likely have more issues actually hitting
the weak spots than getting hit yourself
because you can't lock onto them this
makes the fight quite tough for mages
especially if you don't have any daggers
or swords to back you up or any spells
that do aoe damage for the most part
though his moves are quite slow with the
only one to look out for is the hand
that's brought from his stomach high
king woolner's weakness is the bracelets
on his arm furthermore due to his large
size many of his attacks have a long
wind-up and low combo so don't expect
woolner to swing two or three times the
blackness that surrounds the back of his
body can be quite tough to get out of
especially if you aren't aware that he's
going to charge you halfway through the
fights but for the most part it's really
just about hugging his arms and getting
in as many hits as possible once you do
destroy a bracelet an animation will
play that immobilizes woolner for a bit
giving you enough time to run over and
get working on the next one as for yorm
he has the largest health pool in the
game at around 27 000 however he falls
into this category due to his massive
weakness we'll get into the lore of this
item later but there's a sword in the
boss room called storm ruler that is
intended to be used in this fight
hitting his legs do close to zero damage
so it forces the player to use this
weapon the hardest part about yarm is
actually knowing that you need to use
the storm ruler as to my knowledge is
never explained to the player that there
is even a weapon made to kill him plus
the weapon is located at the other end
of the boss room behind him so you're
more than likely focused on the giant in
front of you rather than the item on the
ground what i do appreciate about this
fight though is that despite the crutch
weapon yorm is still a tough fight as
its main damage requires a charge up and
will only do a couple thousand damage at
a time meaning you'll have to repeat
this action quite a bit it's obvious
though that these weaknesses were meant
to help the player but that doesn't mean
they're the only kind of additions a few
other bosses have their own twists on
the standard bossfight but are meant to
hinder the player instead to start this
off we have the abyss watchers they
don't have too many things to exploit
they are weak to lightning but nothing
drastic to really swing the fight in
your favor about 20 seconds into the
fight another one will spawn making this
a very difficult 2v1 however another 20
seconds later a third one will spawn but
actually help you but he isn't really an
ally more of a third party as he'll
attack you just as much as he attacks
the others the abyss watchers can all be
parried reposted staggered and
backstabbed but good luck finding the
time to actually do that or even the
proper move to perry since they seem to
love sweeping across the floor when
you're far away after the first phase is
done he'll then charge up and use some
fire attacks thankfully no more enemies
spawn so it's just a standard 1v1 but
that doesn't mean the fight is any
easier as his damage is incredibly high
the other is the dragon slayer armor on
its own it's already a tough fight with
a boss carrying a large shield that
blocks all damage in a large axe that
not only does lightning damage but also
comes with a large amount of moves for
both long and short distances but by far
the most annoying part of this fight is
the butterflies outside of the arena as
they'll either shoot out these toxic
balls that whittle away your health or a
large laser that could one shot you if
you're not careful since the butterflies
are outside the arena and cannot be
locked onto you just have to deal with
them and that makes the fight way harder
than it would have been otherwise so
it's clear that a good chunk of the
bosses have some variety to them that
are either intended to hinder or help
the player but while in this case it's
quite obvious to tell what these
additions are meant to do some aren't as
simple going back to the beginning we
have the first boss eutyx gundyr who is
one of the many bosses in this game that
can be parried assuming this is your
first playthrough you're more than
likely not focused on parrying and more
likely just trying to survive once he
enters half health he'll go into his
second phase which will transform into
this black mass this phase is definitely
going to be tougher for first-time
players as it hits hard and has some
awkward timings to keep note of but
during this phase he's actually weak to
black firebombs which coincidentally is
a burial gift you can receive in the
character creation menu taking into
account all the burial gifts we can buy
all of them are either easily acquired
very early in the game going to be
obsolete in a couple hours or just not
worth it at all that's why the black
firebombs have always been my go-to as
even though i never really use
throwables it at least has its uses
within minutes of starting the game the
reason this addition isn't as simple is
because some players may not parry udyx
or know of his weakness in the second
phase so depending on the level of
knowledge the player has and their
current playstyle this fight's addition
may actually make the fight more harder
than it seems three great examples of
this are pontiff the old demon king and
champion gundyr pontiff always starts
the fight with the same move so as long
as you get the timing down you can get
some early damage in thanks to being
parriable however he is still a very
difficult boss so that section between
this attack and the second phase can
still be an uphill battle speaking of
which his second phase can be extremely
hard to manage as he creates a spirit
version of himself it does help in the
sense that it will tell you the move
that pontiff is about to do but the
spirit can also damage you so you can
possibly be hit twice however assuming
you're fast enough and you have a weapon
with enough damage you can completely
eliminate the spirit version of him
while he's summoning it bringing it back
to a 1v1 as for the old demon king he
wields a large hammer and does a ton of
flame moves you can exploit his large
size by going underneath him but he does
have quite a few moves that will prevent
you from getting too close he also has
many different fire attacks such as the
meteor shower and a ring of fire all of
which can take a large chunk of your
health away or even outright kill you if
you aren't careful also this fire attack
he does where he spits out a line across
the ground seems to clip through the
environment which makes this even more
annoying the biggest problem with the
demon king is getting close enough to
him while also trying to avoid many
moves he has that counter this style of
play to make matters worse he's
completely resistant to fire so
pyromancers are going to struggle the
most with this fight thankfully
pyromancers can use spells like poison
mist boulder heave and some black flame
spells which are attacks he won't be
resistant to plus most of these can be
acquired before you even meet him or
even found in the area he's located in
as for champion gundyr he functions
somewhat on the same level as udyx minus
the second phase his second phase is a
much higher damage and more aggressive
version of the first but he can once
again be parried and this continues even
into the second phase the problem here
is that all these additions depend on a
bunch of factors that as a whole either
make the fight easier or harder having a
shield that can parry makes these fights
much easier as to post to not having one
but on the other hand having a slower
weapon can make the fight tougher such
as with pontiff or gundyr or in the case
of the old demon king your entire build
can be practically useless just by them
existing however despite these i really
love these decisions a lot it creates
discussion about the boss's difficulty
allowing them to not fall into the same
pit that the deacons of the deep fall
into where everyone unanimously agrees
that they're easy it also creates that
spark that some may need to keep playing
these games i've created many characters
in this game i've made strength
dexterity sorcery and pyromancy builds
and each time there's always one boss
that gives me more trouble that the
previous build didn't such as with the
abyss watchers who were quite trivial
when i used the melee weapon but when
swapping to magic they became tougher as
they were too fast for my spells it just
goes to show not only how great these
bossfights are in general but how unique
they are once you switch up your
playstyle it makes the game feel fresh
again and gives you plenty of reasons to
keep playing however this fun factor
cannot be said for all bosses some of
these individuals suffer from either an
awful route to the boss room or the
infamous camera this walk that i've
dubbed the walk of shame is the route
you must take from the bonfire to the
boss room every time you fail sometimes
it's right next to the fog wall without
much interference sometimes it's a long
walk but a shortcut can prevent any
issues however some bosses like with
yorm and aldrich require the player to
travel a very long distance to reach
them not only does this take away from
the actual time you could be fighting
the boss meaning you'll be learning less
from them over a longer period of time
but most of them are riddled with
enemies that can either kill you on the
way there or do enough damage to warren
to heal that you could have saved for
the boss thankfully though this really
isn't that big of a problem as dark
souls 3 compared to the previous games
is actually very forgiving when it comes
to its bonfire placement as for the
camera anyone who's ever played a
soulsborne game can come to the
agreement that the toughest enemy in the
game is the camera this usually comes up
in discussions when talking about
dragons or giants as they're the main
reason as to why the camera refuses to
cooperate since the enemy is large the
most optimal place to do damage is
behind or underneath them this has been
a tactic in every game in the franchise
making this the go-to method to
defeating larger enemies the problem is
that the camera hates this such as when
you fight the storm drake later on in
the game its legs have damage reduction
so you have to hit it in the head for
maximum damage but depending on where
the storm drake is and what move it does
it can completely screw with the camera
causing you to be confused as to where
you are or just outright unlocking from
the target as much as i hate this it's
been a problem since the beginning so
when you see a giant or a dragon you
already know what to expect that doesn't
mean it's a good thing but at least you
know ahead of time that the camera is
not going to cooperate the same cannot
be said for one specific boss in this
game
oh dear
another dogged contender
the twin princes have the most unfair
combat this game has to offer and that
wording is extremely important to a
degree all bosses have some level of
unfairness to them whether it's delayed
attacks or massive combos but in the
case of the twin princes but more
specifically lorian it's a combination
of inconsistency and camera tracking
that makes this almost too difficult to
handle many times when you die you know
that the reason you died was from your
own mistakes such as when you died when
the boss was at one health because you
healed during an attack you're the only
one to blame for this action and despite
how infuriating it is to have happen you
know there's no one but yourself to
blame but with the twin princes i would
respond and reflect on my decisions and
come up with nothing as a good portion
of my deaths was from things out of my
control lorien is a [ __ ] and thus has
to stumble around on his knees so to
close the gap between him and the player
he has to teleport this might be one of
the most atrocious moves this game has
to offer lorian has quite a few
different attacks a side swipe a thrust
and a slam attack when he teleports then
reappears one of these moves will come
out sometimes it's not even these moves
and can either be another slam that is
much longer or even this short range
slash attack the problem is the lack of
knowledge given to the player on this
move most of the time he'll start his
teleport by holding his sword up but on
occasion he will pull it back like he's
entering a thrust or move it to the side
implying it's a side swipe but neither
of these could happen take this example
here where lorian holds up his hand and
teleports but when he reappears he does
the long slam attack after this move he
then teleports again with the same hand
going up but does the slightly faster
slam attack instead or even in this
example where once again he will raise
his hand then does a swipe but then goes
right into the thrust motion only for it
to be a slam attack again to add even
more problems he has this plunge attack
in his arsenal where he lands on top of
the player in my years of playing this
game i don't think the camera has
actually ever tracked this move once not
only is it problematic that the move
exists at all but lauren will
occasionally stop his two hit side sweep
and only just do one so he can teleport
to do another move which of course
includes this attack and yes the
teleport will unlock the camera if
you're unlucky enough lorian has almost
zero consistency meaning the player
needs to dodge on reaction to the move
rather than anticipating the move he
literally starts his animation with the
problem is that due to the different
timings of these moves you can barely
even do that the thrust and side swipe
are a bit slow which will give the
player more time to react but the pounce
and slam attacks are not and almost
happen immediately so you can't even
dodge on reaction as if you dodge too
early on the thrust you'll be hit but
dodge too late on the slam and plunge
and you'll also be hit if the animations
were consistent then this wouldn't be a
problem and would force the player to
read lori and react accordingly if he
winds up with the thrust then you have
to wait a moment before dodging or if he
starts getting up before teleporting
then you can expect a slam attack and
react accordingly but then this goes
back to the problem earlier where lori
and mix and matches move so it's
impossible to predict what he'll do
however despite all the criticism i
still love this fight in fact i might
rank it in my top 5 along with many of
the other great fights in this game the
addition of lothric in the second phase
further increases the difficulty making
it a truly uphill battle and even though
lothric's moves are just as annoying as
lorian sometimes there are still ways to
avoid them and there's also the added
benefit of being able to damage lothric
on top of lorgan if you hit the right
spot as for lori and his major weakness
like any boss in this game is time every
failure in victory the player gains new
information from their fight and yes
while lorian doesn't really provide you
much of that most of the time after a
while you will be able to master him
there's even a way to prevent lorien
from teleporting without the use of
glitches that just involves you being in
a specific spot in relation to the boss
and hitting him enough times to prevent
him from using another attack you can
even avoid the majority of lothric's
orbs by other being extremely far away
from the duo which causes lorien to walk
closer before teleporting or when
lothric releases his orbs you just focus
on lorian's moves as for the most part
they attack at the same time despite its
extremely annoying mechanics this is
still one of my favorite fights in the
game this lineup of 19 bosses is
exceptional each of them is unique in
their own way even when it's literally
the same fight twice the presentation of
these fights is also spectacular as
these cutscenes really show how menacing
these bosses are and i'm glad they
didn't overdo it this time on the
cutscenes as instead of having all the
main bosses get one it's only a select
few making them feel more unique and
exciting as a cutscene implies that the
boss is truly going to be something
worth fighting it's due to this variety
and uniqueness within the bosses that
makes me come back time and time and
again as by simply changing to a new
weapon you can explore a whole new side
of these fights you would have never
seen before and it's truly one of the
strongest parts of dark souls 3.
seeing as we've covered everything else
and i've definitely delayed it long
enough i think it's finally time we talk
about the story earlier in the video i
said that if you're a newcomer to the
franchise and your first game was elven
ring then the next game you should play
to have the smoothest transition would
be dark souls 3 where this argument is
completely destroyed is when talking
about the story
obviously if you're here to experience
the story then you should definitely
start with dark souls 1 to get the full
picture but if you're really not in the
mood to play the previous games for
whatever reason and just want to play
this one then for the most part you
really don't need to understand too much
there is quite a few characters and
references to past games that will lose
their impact should you skip ahead
though like seaguard and sigmar andre
being present in both games the soul of
cinder music theme being a slight
altered version of gwyn's theme and the
backstory of the abyss watchers making
very little sense if you're unaware who
artorius is but the great thing about
the dark souls games is the time frame
between them all three games take place
at different times and at different
places so most things that will occur in
the previous games won't have too much
relevance in future titles so you
probably can get away with playing just
the third game but i of course do
recommend starting from the beginning
speaking of which to explain the story
of dark souls 3 we need to go back
momentarily to dark souls 1. at the
beginning of time there was a world that
was shrouded in gray fog giant trees and
everlasting dragons and there was an age
called the age of ancients eventually
fire was created and within the first
flame was the souls of lords four people
being nito izalith gwyn and the pygmy
consumed these souls and became lords
the pygmy is quite easily forgotten
according to the text but he is
responsible for all human life while the
other three band together to overthrow
the dragons and usher in a new age
called the age of fire this was a
prosperous time for the world as the
kingdom of lordran was created for all
the lords and their acquaintances but
flames can't last forever fearing the
age of fire would come to a close gwyn
would link himself to the first flame
thus becoming the kindly needed for the
flame to burn longer every dark souls
game has the same exact plot relink the
flame and continue the age of fire where
the games differ from one another though
is when you take into account who we the
player are and why the fire isn't being
linked in dark souls 1 we are the chosen
undead who is referred in a great
prophecy is the one who will link the
fire and succeed gwyn in dark souls 3
however we are the ashen one since the
age of fire is still going on in dark
souls 3 that means the canon ending for
the previous games that are characters
linked to the fire but one thing to
remember is that we're not the only ones
who tried to link it we meet a ton of
other undead who have risen thanks to an
undead curse but we're the only ones who
have actually succeeded in dark souls 3
we didn't succeed as the ashen one we
were tasked with linking the flame many
years ago but failed however due to
unique circumstances we are forced to
come back and try again all the dark
souls games take place at different
times remember so different kingdoms and
nations have been built over time across
the games you go from lordran to
draenleic to now lothric but there is
tons of other kingdoms that were
probably built between these games
meaning there is a lot of people who've
linked the flame this is relevant as the
current person to link the flame next is
lothric the young prince of the kingdom
lothric except he refused to link the
flame because lothric refused the bell
of awakening has awoken some of the
previous lords from different times so
that they may relink the flame again but
they also refused it was a last ditch
effort the bells of awakening re-woke us
because all the lords refused to link
the flame we're then tasked with taking
their souls and using them to link the
flame ourselves to help us with the
linking of the flame is the fire keeper
because in this game we actually start
with a maiden but already this poses an
interesting question why are they
refusing is it out of self-interest or
is there something else going on what
seems to be that the lords simply just
don't see the point anymore many of them
come from different backgrounds and
possess different ideologies which ends
up making their reasons entirely
different the abyss watchers are a squad
of troops or are dedicated to combating
the abyss this underworld of darkness
where nothing good ever comes out in
fact woolner was consumed by the abyss
which is where we go to fight him when
we touch his chalice it said that the
abyss watchers served in the name of
artorius who also had the same objective
of combating the abyss except just like
artorius they too were also infected by
said abyss which is why they fight each
other as their comrades are under the
influence of the abyss and must be
stopped they are now a fragment of the
group they used to be and are too
focused on stopping the abyss from
consuming themselves that they have no
time to link the flame jjorn was the
descendant of an ancient conqueror and
was tasked with commanding the people
and serving as their blade and shield
many doubted him though so he created
two weapons that were able to slay him
which is the storm rulers we use in his
boss fight however four women who would
eventually become the four hand monsters
we find in the profaned capital
triggered a curse that created the
profaned flame this flame engulfed
yorm's kingdom and killed everyone he
then took it upon himself to put the
profane flame to rest ultimately
sacrificing his life and becoming a lord
of cinder why he refused to link the
flame again is unknown but it's assumed
that he most likely just wished for a
swift death so that he never has to
think of how he failed to protect the
people of his kingdom but now that he's
awake again he has to sulk and live with
his failure once again aldrich was a
former cleric who began to see visions
of a deep sea this made him delve deeper
into these visions and caused him to go
a bit insane developing a habit of
consuming humans among these humans were
also children and there's also a theory
going around that henri and horus were
the only two kids to escape his grasp he
would then somehow become lord of cinder
but upon being revived he refused he saw
more visions but not of a deep sea but
of complete darkness and decided to see
the age of darkness through by refusing
to link the flame within these images of
darkness he saw images of the old gods
like gwyn and his children so he sought
out to devour them which is why he
traveled to honor orlando and killed
gwyndolin we know this because of the
signature mask aldridge has and in the
final case of lothric he was born of an
agreement between the king and queen of
lothric where they planned on having a
child perfect enough to survive the
linking of the flame and become a lord
of cinder but in doing so they produced
a curse it's unclear what the curse
really is but it's caused lother to be
extremely frail and weak and made lorien
a mute and a [ __ ] since the two are
linked they both need to link the flame
together but whether it was because of
the curse his brother or something else
entirely the two ultimately decided to
refuse which is what set the game's plot
in motion this is more or less a
summarized version of the events but you
get the main idea they're incredible
backstories and are all unique enough to
make the discovery interesting as the
abyss watchers refused out of a lack of
purpose yarn refused because of his own
failure and despair and lothric probably
out of spite for the curse and the rules
of being a lord that were put onto him
from birth the only issue once again is
that it's told through item descriptions
dark souls has always been about
creating its world through the items we
find in game and this argument has been
around for ages but for my personal
thoughts on it i've never liked the item
descriptions as the main source of lore
i deal with it since it's going to be
like this for the foreseeable future but
if i had to choose i'd prefer not to as
many things are still left up in the air
due to the small amount of text you can
fit in the item description the dark
souls series has some of the best lore
i've ever read but the way it's
uncovered has always dampened the
experience not only can it be a slog to
read through all the text but many
people won't even bother to read it or
even know that it exists at all going
back to my previous video about eldon
ring's story which by the way thank you
all for the support on that video and if
you haven't seen it i highly recommend
your due if you confused about the story
but in that video i got tons of comments
asking me how i even came up with
everything i said in the video and it
made me realize how many people don't
actually know where the lore comes from
it's not their fault though because dark
souls at least to me is the only game
i've ever played where the lore is
strictly through item descriptions and
it's because of this uniqueness that
causes many people to cast aside the
information thinking it's just some
flavor text like i said the lore of dark
souls is incredible but its delivery of
said lore has always been awful speaking
of awful another major debate within
these games is the npcs the biggest
argument being that the game needs a
quest log to keep track of the npcs and
their quest lines and that they don't
explain where they go the first part is
something i've never agreed with too
many games hold the player's hand when
it comes to quests so when a game
finally forces me to find things on my
own i feel more invested in the story
most of the time in other rpg games you
can skip through all the dialogue
without a care in the world as the game
will give you the exact location anyway
but dark souls forces you to listen
making you actually invested in the
story without you even knowing it
however the latter half of the argument
i agree with to an extent the main issue
though is the lack of information most
npcs don't tell the player where they'll
go next making it even harder sometimes
they give hints but it's nothing
concrete for example before this massive
swamp the player must crawl through
early in the game they'll encounter
horus and henry they give you some
backstory as to why they're there but
there isn't much more to it than that
thankfully most of the npcs in this game
will show up at firelink shrine so it'll
be hard to miss them but once at
firelink anri will talk about trying to
defeat aldridge so she at least gives
you some clue as to where she'll be but
what she doesn't tell you is that you
have to meet her in smoldering lake and
then at irithyll before you can meet her
at the boss room now i'll admit this is
probably a bit biased as henry has ties
to one of the later endings in the game
which is extremely complex but another
good example would be secret you meet
secret on a required path so it'll be
hard to miss him the first puzzle of his
is also not too bad as well as he
appears near the direction you're
heading so you'll still end up crossing
paths afterwards though is where things
take a turn his next location is inside
this well he's apparently been tricked
and pushed inside so we have to help him
get out so we need his armor now
technically the proper way to do this is
to progress through the story normally
and find sigward but then actually end
up getting tricked as it's actually
patches but there's still a chance you
can mess this up by climbing the rafters
first which leads to the other side of
the walkway where he traps you on so he
doesn't appear if you screwed this up
like i did intentionally for this
playthrough you'll need to trigger
patches to spawn by using the tower key
and getting trapped by him there you
then need to go back to firelink find
him upstairs and then buy siegward's
armor off him i'd like to point out that
i've done this questline a dozen times
or so so i know all the intricacies to
it but as a new player you may never
even meet patches and even if you do you
wouldn't know that he's actually the
culprit since if you cross the rafters
first then he obviously won't appear so
you obviously won't know to buy his
armor off him unless you look at his
inventory thankfully the rest of the
questline though is somewhat
straightforward as he shows up in
irithyll which is once again a required
path and then the last location will be
in the irithyll dungeon which he says is
his next location finding the exact area
of where he is can be a bit tricky as
it's not only hidden you'll need a set
of keys to unlock him only then can you
finish his quest line where the two of
you defeat yorm together this is the
same for a majority of the npcs most of
the time it's straightforward but
there's always those one or two steps
that give you zero information to
clarify as well even though his location
in irithyll and the dungeon aren't too
hard to find if you don't get him out of
the well he can't continue his journey
so you may pass through these areas then
come back to find secret in the well and
be even more confused as you've already
gone through the area he was going to
spawn in it seems like it was intended
for the player to rescue him first and
then cross paths with him later which is
why he never explains where he's going
but once again if you do this backwards
there's almost a zero percent chance
you'll be finding him as always though i
do want to mention that for the most
part whether it's npcs or item
descriptions i don't necessarily mind
them i'm also having the game push me to
learn the lore or to make me think when
it comes to npcs but sometimes it does
go a bit too far getting back on track
to the story once the lords are all
defeated we can start the ending after
gathering all the souls on the lords we
can now use the bonfire to teleport us
to the kiln of the first flame and this
is without a doubt one of the most
gorgeous places in the game it's so rich
with lore as just the environment itself
tells a story this whole area is covered
in buildings and rubble all of this is
from past kingdoms and dynasties that
have existed since the beginning of time
itself but by far the best part of this
area is the boss the soul of cinder is
the final boss in dark souls 3 and
probably has the coolest backstory in
the whole game which is that it's us
well
sort of the soul of cinder is the
manifestation of all the warriors who've
linked the flame meaning our characters
from dark souls 1 and 2 are a part of
this group we are essentially fighting
ourselves as well as a dozen other
warriors this is further reinforced by
the soul of cinder doing dodge rolls
something only the player can do and
also has the ninja flip which was from a
ring in dark souls 1. this boss flight
in general is really great as he has an
entire arsenal of weapons from magic to
melee and he isn't afraid to use all of
them once the second phase hits he just
switches back to the coiled sword which
is the same one we've stuck in the
bonfires this entire time and he duels
us gwyn's theme also plays during this
fight which is such a great homage to
the past games and makes you feel
nostalgic about your journey through the
trilogy it is one of the best boss
fights in the game and is the best way
i've seen a game and a series after this
though we do get some endings of which
there are four the first is the most
obvious and that is the linking of the
flame however one thing to note though
is the flame itself compare this
cutscene to dark souls 1 and it's clear
that it doesn't have that same spark
anymore the game is implying that what
we are doing is just delaying the
inevitable and that the flame will die
no matter how hard we try so what's the
point in delaying it the second and most
likely canon option is the age of dark
we finally snuff out the flame and usher
in an age of darkness it's gone on too
long the flame keeps going out and
nothing is getting better so what's the
point in continuing by stopping this age
we can at least start something new and
just see what happens within the age of
darkness the world is completely black
and it is so dark that my torch couldn't
even light the ground near me this
sounds quite grim but it doesn't seem
all that bad as the fire keeper
reassures us that the flame will
eventually return but probably not in
our lifetime there is an alternate to
this ending where in the few short
seconds you can move around if you
attack the fire keeper you'll
simultaneously snuff out the flame but
also take the flame for yourself
possibly out of power or of
self-interest the fourth ending called
the usurpation of fire is easily one of
the hardest in the game to complete as
the wiki has a 12-step guide on how to
achieve this ending it's extremely
complex but sees the ashim one become
not a lord of lothric but a lord of
londor it's unclear what or where londor
is but it seems to be a land filled with
hollows it has many ties to characters
and places in past games and would have
been a great dlc if we ever got that
it's also a nice alternative as the game
always seems to give the player two
choices one of darkness and one of light
but this gives us a sort of loophole as
both occur at the same time it's a nice
ending and has been the start of many
theories allowing the playerbase to
paint their own picture of what londor
truly is speaking of painting a picture
we can now talk about the dlc dark souls
3 comes with two dlcs ashes of ariendel
and the ring city a bit disconnected
from the main story the two dlcs do tie
into one another ash's very endel starts
with the player entering the cleansing
chapel and finding an old man on the
ground this is a man named gail who
offers us this piece of a painting and
upon touching it sends us into the
painted world of ariandel this isn't the
first time a painted world has existed
in the series but it's definitely a
first for this game basically these
paintings are of other worlds father
ariendo created this painted world for
those who had nowhere else to go such as
the followers of pharyn who are the
followers of the abyss watchers after
the abyss watchers became lords of
cinder their home became infested with
rot and poison so they sought refuge in
ariandel it's unclear what sparked the
initial decision for father ariendel to
make the painting but it could be a
combination of the age of fire slowly
fading away and an attempt to revive the
old painted world of ariamis but these
painted worlds are actually quite ironic
as they have their own rekindling of the
flame instead of the darkness consuming
the world there's this rot that takes
over the painted world and to prevent
this rot from taking over we need flames
to burn it away that's why gail made us
enter the painting because the lady he
serves is stuck in here and we need to
set fire to the painting so that she may
see flame and continue her painting it's
interesting as just as the world of dark
souls is rotting away thanks to the
people keeping the flame lit oriendo is
running away because they refuse to
light the flame as we roam through the
painted world we'll come across the
church with a nun named freda sitting
alone she's the main reason this world
refuses to heal all the bird-like
creatures called corvians made up their
minds to burn the painted world and thus
remove all the rot from the world but
frida convinced father ariandel to not
burn it she also tells us to constantly
leave and that we should not meddle in
her affairs assuming we don't listen we
can meet her bodyguard wilhelm and upon
defeating him drops a key that leads to
an attic which has the little girl that
we've been trying to find our job is now
to show her flames which isn't exactly
the most descriptive objective but it's
quite easy to assume that it somehow
involves the main boss of the dlc
speaking of bosses ashes of ariandel
comes with only two the first is the
optional boss champion's gravetender who
halfway through the fight will summon
his giant wolf and the other boss is
sister freda after killing wilhelm she
tells us to leave and not come back but
if we keep exploring the painted world
we can find a hidden lever that opens up
a secret area behind the church that
reveals the true location of father
ariandel it's also here where we get to
see how he was able to suppress the
flames from spreading in the painted
world and that's by flailing himself and
using his blood to smother the flame the
boss fight then starts as we take on
sister freda and after her death father
ariendo goes mad with rage and reignites
the flames that were meant to be
suppressed simultaneously burning the
church and also reviving sister frida
you then have to fight the two together
and as if that wasn't bad enough she
gets up again and has a third phase
where she transforms into black flame
frida this is an incredibly tough fight
not necessarily damage wise but just a
length is trying to conserve your estes
for three whole phases is such a pain
however upon defeating her a third time
she will finally be dead we discover
from her bossel that she was the first
ash to enter the painting before sending
us into the painted world gail tells us
in the beginning that two ash will bring
the flame back to ariandel we're the
second and frida is the first that line
of two ash bringing the flame back was
not meant as to ash's cooperating but
rather their inevitable battle that
would spark the flame the world needed
after this fight assuming you have the
next dlc you can take this bonfire in
the boss room to the drag heap where the
ring city begins ash's very endel is a
pretty short dlc it can take anywhere
from two to four hours to complete
depending on how tough the bosses are or
how much you want to explore on its own
it seems a little hard to justify its 15
price tag but these days you get less
content for more so i can't be too upset
plus it's meant to be played with the
ring city as for the ring city this is
the final dlc for the game and is just
as good as the previous one it has
double the bosses compared to the
previous dlc and also comes with new
locations and lore the ring city is a
city at the edge of the world quite
literally if you remember from the story
section we talked about those four lords
from dark souls 1 being gwyn izalithnito
and the pygmy well so thanks for helping
create the age of fire gwen created a
city from the rest of the world that
belongs to the pygmy remember the pygmy
was the creator of humanity and is thus
our ancestor so our bloodline originated
here not only does that mean the pygmy
was here but also the original dark soul
is here as that was the soul the pygmy
obtained during the age of ancients
another being of importance that is
located here is philianar one of gwyn's
children before we actually enter the
ring city we must go through the drag
heap which we can actually see a glimpse
of from the kiln of the first flame it's
a piece of land that has been filled
with ruined civilizations that have all
become morphed into an ash-filled
wasteland this area like many of the
places in the souls games are just great
to look at these games are really tough
but there's always those moments of
bliss in between them where you can just
look out into the horizon and are left
in odd how wonderful it looks to get to
the ring city we must fight the first
boss who are a duo of demons this fight
is actually quite tough as you fight
them as a duo but then have to fight the
last one as a more buffed up version of
itself called the demon prince it's once
again another unique take on the
standard boss fight and was a really
cool twist the first time around
afterwards we can make it to the ring
city and it's extremely elegant it's
also very dangerous the person behind
this is the large figure in the back who
is a part of the spears of the church a
covenant in the game who is dedicated to
protecting philly nor to get to villiano
we have to defeat half-light our second
boss of the dlc and probably the most
unique boss in the game as havoc can be
replaced by a player due to this game's
age it most likely won't happen anymore
but on release it was quite common to
actually be summoned as the boss for
this fight which is such a genius idea
after half flight is dead we can come
face to face with villianor who leads to
the final boss but before we get into
that we have to talk about the secret
boss of this dlc dark eater madeir who
originally was just a simple dragon on a
bridge but becomes a full boss if you
find the secret room he is undoubtedly
the hardest boss in the whole game he
has these extremely high damaging moves
that can one shot you most of the time
and his fast speed makes a lot of them
hard to dodge plus he's a dragon so he
has very high damage resistance in his
legs and his held is over 15 thousand
only being beaten out by sister freed in
yorm which just in case you forgot one
contains a weapon used to defeat the
boss and the other has three phases of
health getting back to filling our when
we touch her egg it shatters and it
seems to accelerate time to a future
version of the ring city one that is
destroyed and covered in sand and ash
some have also claimed that this isn't
the case and that the ring city we see
in game is just merely an illusion and
we just broke that illusion but what's
for certain though is something
definitely happened as we walk in this
barren wasteland we finally find gail
gail was tasked by his lady the painter
with finding a suitable pigment for her
painting which was the blood of the dark
soul and the best place to get it is the
ring city the ring city is populated
with pygmy lords who have all descended
from the original pygmy owner of the
dark soul meaning all their blood has
traces of the dark soul within it the
problem is that the pigment needs to be
suitable for the painting which is why
he took their blood but after years of
gathering blood it started to dry up so
he consumed it hoping it would still
retain a liquid state there is a theory
about this and one i find incredibly
interesting and it's that gail knew this
state of madness he enters because of
the blood would happen so he left clues
around the ring city like these tattered
pieces of cloth from his cape to guide
us to him so that we may kill him take
the fresh blood from his body and then
give it to the painter so she can use it
in her painting i can't confirm whether
that is true or not but it is such a
good theory gail's boss fight is
objectively the best boss fight in the
whole game from the arena to the combat
to the lore building around this fight
it's all just perfect what really sealed
this decision for me was that gail is
the final boss of the game if you play
the game now technically the soul of
cinder is but as someone who played the
game on release the ring city is the
final piece of content we ever received
so technically the final boss was gail
and it's such a good send off to not
only the game but the series as the
final boss isn't some god or significant
figure but just a nobody who worked
tirelessly to get stronger just as we
worked tirelessly to also get stronger
our strengths then clash at the literal
end of the world with only one of us
coming out alive once we defeat gail we
can go back to the painter and give her
the pigments which he thanks us for
nothing comes from this and it's unclear
what will happen in the future but just
like many of dark souls plots it has
been the topic of many theories within
the community some say it's just another
world but some say it's more meta and
that this new world would be created in
the same way the original world of dark
souls was created implying that the
original game is also in a painting
sadly unless another game in the series
gets created there will never be a
confirmed answer to this so i try not to
dwell on this too much both ashes of
ariandel and the ring city are fantastic
dlcs their decision to make their own
story its own separate narrative but
have lore that links back to the main
story was incredibly well done and
really shows just how good the writing
of this game is the boss fights level
design enemies and gameplay are just
great honestly i have nothing negative
to say about this content as a whole it
was not only a great way to end the
series of dark souls but for new players
it will serve as a great change of pace
to the overall flow of the main game as
for my final thoughts dark souls is one
of my favorite games in the franchise
and easily the best in the souls trilogy
its combat flows smoothly from fight to
fight it has gorgeous levels and
locations and a compelling narrative
that seeks to question the original
game's stories and while there were some
contentious additions to the game there
are such minor issues that they don't
even come close to plaguing the overall
experience the series as a whole is
phenomenal and it's because of this game
that i was able to experience it and i
couldn't be more thankful
with that we've finally come to the end
of the video and if you've made it this
far thank you it felt great to boot this
game up again and if i'm being honest it
probably won't be the last time i do it
either it's such a unique game that i
always find reasons to come back and
play it such as today where the main
motivation was just to be able to tell
all of you why i love the game so much
regardless thank you all for watching
like the video if you enjoy and
subscribe if you're new and as always
thank you to my returning viewers for
coming back to another video also during
the production of this i hit over 100
000 subs so once again thank you all for
that
as usual though take care everyone and
goodbye
[Music]
you